- Good evening ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to the 14th
Annual Governor's Awards.
Please take your seat.
Welcome everybody, to the
Dolby's Theaters holding room.
This is a multipurpose room
for overflow of talent.
Have a seat, thank you, find your tables.
Ladies and gentlemen, find your tables.
We have to be outta here by 10:00 PM.
There is a corporate event
for some personal injury
attorneys coming in.
(audience laughs)
They will be using the same decorations.
Please find your seats, everybody.
Let's all sit down.
If you don't sit down,
I'm gonna bring Terrence Howard up here
and he'll explain his new
geometry and it's not fun.
Everyone sit down, let's do this.
Hello, ladies and
gentlemen, it is an honor,
and a favor to be here.
This is a strategic obligation.
It is a pleasure to stand
here on this temporary stage.
For those of you that don't recognize me
from the Tuesday night AA
meeting in the Palisades,
(audience laughs)
my name is John Mulaney.
If you don't know, thank you.
(audience cheers)
That's very nice.
If you don't know who I
am, that's totally fine.
I'm like Louis Farrakhan.
I mean a lot to a very
small group of people.
(audience laughs)
You know, it's such an honor
for me to be hosting this.
Growing up as a boy,
I would always watch the
non-televised Governor's Awards,
even though they only
started 14 years ago.
My family, we'd gather in
front of the turned off TV.
It was the only time I
ever saw my dad smile.
And I'd think, "Someday,
that's gonna be me."
Look at this room full of
people, this is a solid room.
We have so many fantastic
people in this room.
Everybody in this room,
knows something about
somebody else in this room,
that nobody else knows.
(audience laughs)
Isn't that fun?
And if you don't know
something about someone else
in this room that no one else knows,
you should leave the business,
'cause you have absolutely
no pull whatsoever.
(audience laughs)
Look at the amazing talent in this room.
Mr. Bradley Cooper is here.
Bradley Cooper.
(audience cheers)
The incredible director
and star of "Maestro,"
or as it was originally
titled, "Bye, Felicia."
Bradley worked for six years,
to do six minutes of accurate
conducting in the film.
That is, may I say something,
dude, that is very cool.
Just FYI, none of us know
what accurate conducting looks like.
You could have literally done anything.
People were like, "This is the scene
where he perfectly conducts."
I was like, "I'll take your word for it."
(audience laughs)
How about the cinematic masterpiece,
that is "Oppenheimer,"
ladies and gentlemen.
(audience cheers)
Oh my God.
Like a lot of you, I spent
the first two and a half hours
of Oppenheimer thinking,
"They only gave Rami Malek one line?
Why did he show up for one line?
Is the catering good or something?"
That "Oppenheimer" cast
is stacked with talent.
Every part is played by a huge movie star.
They're like, "Hey, we need an extra
to polish the atom bomb.
Let's see if Jack Nicholson is available."
Daniel Day-Lewis plays a pair of goggles.
I'm fully kidding, he doesn't.
Ladies and gentlemen, you're looking at me
and you're thinking, "Oh, great.
Another goddamn standup comedian
here to make fun of us
at our sacred rituals."
Well, I'll have you know,
I'm not such an outsider.
I am quite sought after in the film world.
I would like to share
with you a real email
that I got from my
agents about 30 days ago.
This is an actual email that
they sent me on December 7th,
so you'll get an idea of
who you're dealing with.
(audience laughs)
(John clears throat)
"John, in anticipation of
our conversation attached,
please find the untitled Maggie
Gyllenhaal project written
and to be directed by Maggie Gyllenhaal."
That makes sense.
"Emma Tillinger Koskoff, Osnat Handelsman,
and Talia Kleinhandler are attached
to produce for Warner Brothers.
Christian Bale is negotiating
to star opposite Jessee Buckley."
I know who one of those people is.
"There is no script
available at this time."
Okay, I'm listening.
(audience laughs)
"Pending, pending your
response to the material.
Please use the attached
sides to put yourself
on tape for the role of Young Cop."
(audience laughs)
Let's, thank you.
(audience cheers)
They really sent this to me.
WME sent this to me, let me be clear.
I'm not being offered Young Cop.
(audience laughs)
They're giving me the chance
to throw my hat in the ring.
And yes, I put myself on tape,
and, no, I didn't get it, but...
(audience laughs)
Let's stop focusing on failure, all right?
Enough failure.
Tonight, there are only winners.
We are honoring four
individuals tonight whose love
and labor and creativity made
an indelible mark in film.
And by film I mean movies.
Tonight we honor a man that I think
is the funniest person to ever live.
Mr. Mel Brooks.
(audience cheers)
Mel.
"The Producers," "Blazing
Saddles," "Young Frankenstein,"
"Silent Movie," "History of the World."
Mel Brooks, ladies and gentlemen.
(audience cheers)
Mel, Mel Brooks, or his
antisemites call him, "Exhibit A."
(audience laughs)
Do you know the guy that did
the prosthetic nose for "Maestro?"
He did Mel's entire face and body
and personality for the last 97 years.
Did you know this?
Mel Brooks not only produced "The Fly,"
and "The Elephant Man,"
but he took his name
and EP credit off the film,
so that the audience
wouldn't confuse the genre.
Isn't that amazing?
Can you imagine anyone else in this room,
not taking credit for
something they actually did?
I cannot.
Tonight we're also honoring
a legendary film editor,
Carol Littleton, ladies and gentlemen.
(audience cheers)
Carol, Carol Littleton's
work is incredible.
She's edited "The Accidental Tourist,"
"Swimming to Cambodia,"
Steven Spielberg's "ET,"
which before she got to it
was called "Extraterrestrial."
(audience laughs)
Her Lifetime Achievement
Award is in editing.
Wouldn't it be funny if her
speech was way too long?
(audience laughs)
Do you know, it was
Carol Littleton's hand,
that cut a young Kevin Costner,
completely out of the
movie, "The Big Chill?"
Kevin Costner was originally
in "The Big Chill."
He played Alex, their college
friend who's passed away,
and apparently Director
Lawrence Kasdan really liked
young Costner's performance.
But it was Carol Littleton
who said, "Nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
Not that guy."
(audience laughs)
When I saw "Oppenheimer," I was like,
"Did Carol Littleton get her
hand on Rami Malek's part?
This has the Costner slash
written all over it."
I am speechless, by the
way, to be in the same room,
as our next honoree.
The incredible Ms. Angela Bassett.
Angela.
(audience cheers)
Hey, wow.
"Boyz n the Hood," "What's
Love Got to Do with It?"
"Black Panther," she is the best.
If I may get personal for
a second here, Angela,
this is extra special for me.
See, growing up as a boy in the Midwest,
I went to a lot of movies,
but I never felt like
I saw myself on the big screen
until I was 12 years old.
And I saw a movie called
"Waiting to Exhale,"
and I said, "That's me.
(audience laughs)
I am Bernadine."
Here's what a great
actor Angela Bassett is.
She got a Oscar nomination
for a Marvel movie.
That's like getting a Pulitzer
Prize for a Reddit comment.
(audience laughs)
Finally, tonight, we are presenting
the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award
to the founding senior director
of the Sundance Institute's
Artist Programs,
Michelle Satter.
(audience cheers)
Thank you, Michelle.
Past recipients of the
Jean Hersholt Award include
Frank Sinatra, Angelina
Jolie, and Tyler Perry.
So it's really unclear
what this award means.
(audience laughs)
Michelle's work with the Institute,
has helped launch the careers
of countless film legends,
and it continues to foster
the brilliant emerging voices of tomorrow.
On behalf of everyone, thank you Michelle.
(audience cheers)
I know we're having a lot of
fun, but it's award season.
There's a lot of emotion
and expectation in the air.
Some of you're probably even aware
that voting ends in seven days.
(audience laughs)
I was reminded recently of
something Al Pacino once said,
about what it's like to be an
artist at the Academy Awards,
and if you would indulge me,
I'd like to share it now.
I think it's quite apt for
this evening, and this is real.
So the Playboy interviewer guy says...
(audience laughs)
Says, "Have you ever been to the Oscars?"
And this is what Pacino said.
"I was at the Oscars once for "Serpico."
That was the second time I was nominated.
I was sitting in the third or
fourth row with Diane Keaton.
Jeff Bridges was there with his girl.
No one expected me to
come, I was a little high.
Somebody had done something
to my hair, blew it out
or something, and I looked
like I had a bird's nest
on my head, a real mess.
At one point, I turned to Jeff Bridges,
and I said, "Hey, looks
like there won't be time
for the Best Actor awards."
He gave me a strange look,
and said, "What are you talking about?"
I said, "It's over, the hour is up."
He said, "It's three hours long."
I thought it was an hour TV show.
Can you believe that?
Also, I had to pee, bad,
so I popped a Valium.
Actually, I was eating Valium
like they were candy, chewed on them.
Finally, the Best Actor Award.
Can you imagine the shape I was in?
I couldn't have made it to the stage.
I was praying, please don't let it be me.
Please don't let it be me.
And then I hear, "Jack Lemmon."
I was just so happy I
didn't have to get up,
because I never would've made it.
The Valium was kicking in
and I had to pee so bad."
On that note...
(audience laughs)
Thank you Al, wherever you are.
On that note, let's begin the
14th Annual Governor's Awards.
(dramatic music)